The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right,
today we continue our theme
of integer data structures.
And today we're going to look
at priority queues instead
of the predecessor problem, so
something a little different.
Insert, delete, and find min.
It turns out priority queues
are equivalent to sorting
in the sense that if you have,
normally they say f of n,
but here we're going to
depend on both n and the word
size, priority queue.
Well then, of course you
get a sorting algorithm.
Just insert everything
into the priority queue
and then find min delete,
find min delete, and so on.
So that's the trivial
direction of the equivalence.
But it turns out, both
of these are true.
If you have a sorting
algorithm with n times f time,
then you can convert it
into a priority queue
that in the worst case every
operation takes only f of n, w.
So that's the equivalence
as the result of Thorpe
from a few years ago, 2007.
Kind of a cool breakthrough.
There were earlier versions
that weren't quite as efficient
but this gives you perfect
efficiency, turning any sorting
algorithm into priority queue.
Rough sketch of
the data structure
is you have a bunch of sorting
algorithms which you run now
and then to get little
parts of the input
in order to build an
overall priority queue.
But it's very complicated.
There was an entire
class project
on assimilating it
and understanding it.
It's a bit beyond what we
can cover in the class.
So I'm going to
take this as given
and tell you instead
about sorting algorithms
because there's a major open
problem here which is, can you
sort n integers, n w bit
integers in a word ram's,
word size w in linear time.
We still don't know but we
have a bunch of results.
In particular,
we're going to talk
about a couple
interesting cases where
we can get linear time sorting.
If you've seen radix sort you
know another interesting case
where linear time
sorting is possible.
Interesting open problem here.
Can you get constant
time decrease key?
And ideally, also insertion?
But decrease key would be
handy because then this
would be useful.
In this reduction if you
have a sorting algorithm,
like to get a priority queue
with constant time decrease
key, that would
have applications
to Dijkstra's algorithm.
Of course, if you can
sort in linear time
then everything can be
done in constant time.
So this is not the most
interesting open problem
but it would be a step
in that direction.
Cool.
So let me tell you some
bounds about sorting.
So we have n w bit integers.
And you take any of
these bounds divide
by n you get the priority queue
bound, the best that we know.
So of course, there's comparison
sorting, which takes n log n.
So that's an upper bound.
Trying to beat that.
Trying to get rid of the log.
There's a counting sort from
undergraduate algorithms.
That takes n plus u
time because you need
to build a table of size u.
You've got to zero out
all the initial counts
so that requires order u time.
This is interesting when
the word size equals log n.
So that's a case of
potential interest,
because then 2 to
the w is just n.
So this is linear time.
But even if w is 2 log n,
radix or 1.1 times log n,
then this is bigger n log n.
So, not very good.
But we have radix sort,
which is a bit better.
And this is n times
w divided by log n.
If you do it right you
have some word size w,
you're using counting sort
for each digit in the radix.
So you can afford that the word
size of doing counting sort
to be exactly log n.
Which means you have your
overall word you're dividing
into chunks of size log n.
Each of them you can
do in linear time.
So the number of chunks you have
to do is w divided by log n.
And this is linear if
w equals order log n.
Right, but only then.
So this buys you a little
bit, but still not great.
OK, there's some other
sorting algorithms
we've implicitly seen because
we've seen Van Emde Boas.
I mean, any predecessor
data structure
gives you a priority
queue data structure.
Priority queues-- I didn't
write it, but I mentioned--
insert, delete, find min.
Find min is a weaker operation
than predecessor or successor.
So we can take Van Emde Boas's
predecessor data structure
and convert it into a
sorting algorithm and we
get order n times log w.
Now this is a little
bit tricky to compare.
Of course, log w
sounds better than w.
But there's just divided
by log n, which makes
it a little hard to compare.
It turns out there's
another version.
You can take this
sorting algorithm
and achieve a bound
of m log w over log n.
OK, so this is a slight
improvement in here.
It's similar to your
problem set this week.
This specific
problem was a problem
set in 2005 of this class.
So you can check
it out if you want
to see how to do this
slight improvement.
But now this is clearly
better than this
because here we
have w over log n.
Here I've got a log in front.
So this is a win
over radex sort.
So Van Emde Boas, here's another
way in which is interesting.
It gives us a strict
improvement over radex sort.
And in particular,
actually both of these
are order n log log n if w
is not too big, poly log n.
This doesn't actually
matter but it's
clearly better than this one.
Again, if w is order log n
you get this to be linear.
But in particular, it says
overall you get n log log n up
to w being poly log.
OK, why do we care?
Because there's this
other nice algorithm,
signature sort, which
covers all large word sizes.
And this is an algorithm
we will cover today.
It only works when w is
large, and large means
log to the 2 plus epsilon.
And this is no matter
what epsilon is.
In reality, it's probably
log squared times
log log n squared.
But be a little
sloppy and just say,
a little bit bigger
than log squared.
And then it runs in linear time.
OK, so if you were graphing this
in your mind you've got time
and there's a nice bound
here which is order n.
Then we have everything's
above n log n.
Maybe here we have--
is hard to draw--
n log log n.
This is asymptotic space,
which doesn't really exist,
but you know what I mean.
And then this is the
word size versus log n.
Wow, this is hard to--
this is a really weird picture.
I've never drawn this before.
So you know, initially in
a radex sort, OK log n.
We could get linear time
or order log n, great.
What this is saying
is once you get out
to log the 2 plus epsilon
n you can also do linear.
And from here over
we have linear time.
And here over we
have linear time.
So the question is what about
this middle range between log
n and log to the 2 plus epsilon?
Well, one thing we could do
is use Van Emde Boas sort,
get an n log log n bound.
And so that's one way to fill
in this range in the middle.
And that means overall you can
always sort n integers in n log
log n time.
If w is big you
use signature sort,
if w small use Van
Emde Boas sort.
So this implies n
log log n for all w.
So that's something.
It's not the best known.
Let's see, first result in this
direction was by Han in 2001.
And it achieved this bound,
deterministic and in the ac 0
ram, so without
using multiplication.
Which, I guess Van Emde
Boas doesn't either,
unless I'm missing something.
But it got rid of
the randomisation
which is necessary to get
linear space in Van Emde Boas.
The current best
result on sorting
is by Han and Thorpe in
2002, so a while ago.
They achieved n square
root log w over log n,
which is similar
to this bound, just
has an extra square root here.
So it's a little bit better
than Van Emde Boas sort.
It uses some clever tricks.
It is randomized.
So still the best deterministic
bound is n log log n,
And let's see, we can plug
that in for this range here.
And it will imply that
you get n square root log
log n for all w.
Because in particular,
if w is poly log n,
then this is just log log n.
So you get this bound.
Of course, for all w because
large w are already covered.
So this sorting algorithm is a
little bit messy, and possibly
not the right answer.
I would conjecture you
can sort n integers
in linear time for all w.
But that is a big open problem.
This is the current
state of the art.
So this open question is
really about for small w
when w is poly
log n, or actually
when it's between
log and poly log.
So to give you a piece
of the complete picture
I want to tell you
about signature sort.
Because I think you have
to use different techniques
when w is small versus large.
We know that from fusion
trees and Van Emde Boas.
So I'll tell you about the
slightly large case when
w is at least log to
the 2 plus epsilon,
how to get linear time.
And this is fun.
It uses bit tricks, it
uses a lot of cool ideas,
uses hashing, lots of things.
It also uses another sorting
algorithm called packed sort.
This doesn't fit in
the regular table
because it's for a situation
when more than one input
number fits in a word.
So we're going to let b
denote the number of bits
in the inputs.
So we have b bit integers.
Then when w is at least
b times log n log log n,
so you can fit log n log log
n integers in a single word,
then you can sort
them in linear time.
So it's like your machine
is just a little bit bigger
than what you'd need to
represent the integers,
then all sorting can be
done in a linear time.
And as you might imagine,
this log to the 2 plus epsilon
buys you a little bit of
room with some tricks,
namely hashing.
Right, that's where we're going.
And we'll use yet another
sorting algorithm,
bitonic sort, which
you may have seen.
It's a sorting network.
It's in CLRS up
to second edition,
but it got removed
from third edition.
I guess they thought people
didn't use sorting networks,
but we use sorting
networks here.
Because it gives us parallel
sorting and the word ram
is all about using the
parallelism in your word.
So, we'll get to those.
I'm going to start at the top
level, which is signature sort.
And we're going to
leave things to be done
and then pack sorting
will be one of them.
And bitonic sorting will
be used in pack sorting.
So it's a chain like this.
Cool.
So I'm going to
assume my signature
sort that w is at least
log to 2 pulse epsilon n
times log log n.
This is really just a change
in what epsilon means.
If you're given some
particular epsilon make
it a little smaller,
then you can afford
to add that log log factor.
This is just for convenience.
Now here's the idea.
It's a pretty cool
idea I have to say.
It's by Anderson
and others in 1998.
OK, word size is big,
which is both good and bad.
It means the numbers we
have to sort are big.
They have a lot of bits in
them, way more than log n bits.
But also, we have
this powerful machine
that can handle words
of very large size
and do things and
constant time on them.
I'd like to make some slop.
I want my words to be
bigger than my items,
so first few steps
are about doing that.
The first idea is, well,
you've got this giant word
log to the 2 plus epsilon.
So let's split it into chunks.
And the number of chunks
is log to the epsilon.
So that means each chunk is--
well, it could be even bigger.
So it's at least log squared n.
But it could be bigger
than that because w
is at least log to
the 2 plus epsilon.
So we don't know.
These things are of size w
divided by log to the epsilon
n.
So it's at least log squared.
OK, here's the crazy idea.
We're thinking of our
number being divided
into these chunks, you
know, it's being represented
in some base, 2 to the w
divided by log to the epsilon n.
It's a bit of a mouthful.
But think about these digits.
I claim if you look at a digit,
most values don't appear.
Because how many values
are there for a digit?
Well, it's at least 2
to the log squared n.
That's a big number.
That's way bigger
than polynomial and n.
But how many different
digits are there?
Well, there's n
numbers, each of them
has log to the epsilon n
digits in it appearing.
And so there's roughly a linear
number of digit values total.
But the number of
possible digit values
is 2 to the log log
squared n, which
is huge, super polynomial.
So most digit values don't
appear in our numbers.
So what we're going to
do is hash the digit
values to reduce their space.
Because they're currently living
in a universe of 2 to the log
squared n, but there's
only n times log
to the epsilon n of them.
So we should be able to reduce
to have a much smaller universe
using hashing.
Maybe perfect hashing even.
I mean, we don't have to
be too intelligent here.
Tell you what we get.
What I'd like is to reduce
to a polynomial universe.
And another way to say that is
that the hash values are order
log n bits.
So this lets us go to n
to the 10, or whatever,
which is plenty of room.
We take any universal
hash function,
as soon as you get to
roughly n squared size,
I mean the square of
the number of things,
by a birthday paradox, constant
probability none of them
will hit each other.
That was the second
level of perfect hashing.
We don't need two levels
here, just say OK, user order
log n bits.
You can set this
to 100, whatever.
Then with high probability
you will not get collisions,
so none of the chunks
will hit each other.
So I'm omitting a step
here which is how to--
OK, I'm omitting a
couple of things here.
One of them is I want to
do this in linear time.
Everything has to
be in linear time.
So one front part
is I have to compute
the hash value of
all of these digits
in a single word
in constant time.
So a brief aside, how would
I compute a universal hash
function of these digits
individually in constant time?
Well, my personal favorite
universal hashing scheme
is the multiplication method.
You just need to multiply
by a single value m
and then take it
modular something.
So if I do
multiplication, I mean
if you think of there
being something here,
something here, something here,
m does multiply each
of these individually.
Wow, that's a rough sketch.
I want to hash each of
these guys multiply,
them by the
multiplication method.
This would work fine,
except you get overflows,
which is a bit messy.
So in fact, I'm going to have
to do it for the odd guys
first, multiply them out, mask
out the bits I care about,
then do it for the
even guys separately.
So it's a bit messy.
But hand-wavy proof you can
compute the hash function
of each of these
guys individually,
but in constant time.
So that lets me do this.
You have to then
check for collisions,
which is kind of annoying.
Let's not worry about that.
Set this really high,
very high probability,
there will be no collisions.
Cool.
So at this point we have
mucked up all the digits.
The annoying thing
about this hashing
is we do not preserve order.
It's a little weird for
a sorting algorithm not
preserve order.
The whole point is to
put things in order.
But it's going to be
useful nonetheless.
And so each digit
has been mangled.
Each digit is out of order.
But of course, the
sequence of digits
has been preserved,
in some sense
So, what?
Well, at this point
we can use packed
sorting to sort what remains.
In general packed
sorting can sort n
b bit integers provided
b is small, so w
is at least b log n log log n.
That's the theorem
of packed sorting.
We're going to delay the
coverage of this result
until later.
And I claim that that applies
here because each chunk is now
order log n bits.
And there's log to
the epsilon n bits.
So b is theta log to
the 1 plus epsilon n.
And w is at least log to the 2
plus epsilon times log log n.
OK, so the ratio between
these is as needed.
It's at least log
n times log log n.
OK, so that's why this is good.
There were these things
were huge before.
We've compressed them a lot.
They're at least log square,
now they're only log.
And so now we can
apply packed sorting.
You can fit log times log
log items into one word.
And that's going to make
sorting easy, somehow.
That's to be done.
But now the question is,
suppose we had packed sorting,
how does this help you?
Because this does not sort
the original integers.
It sorts these
integers that have
all of their digits
permuted in some random way.
We have no idea how the hash
function re-orders things.
So we're not done
with signature sort.
It's called signature sort, of
course, because of the hashing.
You're taking signatures
of each of these digits.
Another word for hashes.
All right, next step is to
build a compressed trie.
This is a term we
haven't used yet.
So I'm going to
call these things
that we sorted signatures.
And how many people know
what a compressed trie is?
OK, no one.
Wow, just a few.
So you haven't seen
suffix trees yet.
We're going to cover where
compressed tries come
from in a couple
of lectures but we
get to see them a little early
because they're cool and needed
in this algorithm.
So first notion is
the notion of a trie.
The word trie comes
from retrieval,
from old days when
information retrieval was
what's now called web
searching, or whatever.
So it's now pronounced trie.
It's just another word
for tree, but where
the children of the tree
come from a fixed universe.
We've been working
with tries all the time
in pretty much every lecture
for the last n lectures,
last w lectures, I don't
know, a lot of them.
We said oh, OK, well
let's just consider
the space of all possible keys.
You know, I've drawn this
picture zillion times.
Even when we weren't doing
Van Emde Boas, which actually
stores all of these
things, we were
thinking about fusion
trees like, oh yeah,
so we're storing
this value, and we're
storing this value,
and maybe this value.
And we understand this
corresponds to a 0-bit.
These are 0 and 1 bits.
This is a 1, 0, 1, whatever.
So we understand how to convert
a bit string into this picture.
This is what we
call a binary trie.
I want to do the
same thing over here,
except it's not a binary trie.
Now each digit is giant
so we're going to have
some huge branching factor.
So it's going to be
more like a b-tree.
The first node has a
whole bunch of children.
I'm not going to even--
I mean, it's 2 to the w divided
by log to the epsilon n.
That's the branching factor.
OK, it's big.
That's the number of possible
values in the first digit.
OK.
So then maybe this child
has some node there.
And maybe this one.
Actually, sorry, I didn't
want to draw it that way.
I have a specific trie
in mind, or part of it.
OK, I mean, trie is going
to look something like this.
It's harder to draw, but
it's the larger than binary
equivalent of this picture.
This would be a trie.
So let's think about a
particular situation.
Which is, suppose we just have
two items in this structure.
Then it's easier to draw.
So let's suppose there's
some item over here, x1.
There's some item over here, x2.
Now, generic picture is they
share some common prefix.
This is the common prefix.
It's just to understand some
particular picture here.
Then they diverge, and you know,
then they have their own digit
values.
In some sense, this is the
digit value we care about
because it distinguishes them.
So there's this idea of a
compressed trie, which cleans
up this picture a little bit.
The idea with the compress
trie is very simple.
You draw this trie.
So here, imagine I'm erasing all
the things that do not appear.
Maybe all this is gone.
So I'm just keeping this
part of the structure.
Let's do it for the
binary case first.
The idea in a compress
trie is very simple.
I'm going to contract
every non-branching node
into its parent.
So what that means.
So here I'm storing three
values: 0, 0, 1, 1; 0, 1,
0, 0; and 0, 1, 1, 1.
So some nodes are
non-branching, that's
this node, this
node, and this node.
And the point is well,
why store those nodes?
I mean, there was nothing being
distinguished at that node,
so contract it.
So the new picture if I
redrew this would be 0, 0, 1--
sorry, also this
is non-branching.
So in fact, I'm going
to contract this
into its parent,
this into its parent.
So this whole path,
this non-branching path
will be left with a single edge
which I will label 0, 1, 1.
But it's a single edge
in this structure.
Over here we have an edge 1,
and now we have 0, 0 here,
and 1, 1 here.
That is the compressed
trie representation
of these three values.
The nice thing
about this structure
is every node is branching
except the leaves, which
means the number
of nodes here is
linear in the number of leaves.
That's like twice the number
of leaves minus 1, roughly.
I guess the root might
not be branching.
It has no parent
to contract into.
Whatever.
But more and more
nodes, most 2n nodes.
That's the binary case.
Now over here what we do is in
the corresponding contracted
try a picture of this thing.
Let's see, it's a second edge.
I'm going to put just a label
of 2 on this edge to say, well,
I'm skipping this node.
This guy is non-branching.
So I want to get rid of it and
contract it into the parent.
So now this corresponds
to two edges here.
There are two digits, which
I could write the digits
if I knew what they were.
But particularly I want
to keep track of the fact
that there exactly two of them.
And then there's
a branching node.
That one stays.
But then I actually we'll go
straight to the leaves here.
This will be x1 and x2.
And this will have
a lot of digits.
OK, so some large
number written here.
So that's the idea
with a compress trie.
Now the nice thing
about a compress trie
is they have linear size,
number of edges and vertices
is linear in the
number of leaves,
which is the number of
values we have here.
Another nice thing
about compress tries
is they preserve order.
So if you look at the
order of the leaves
down here it's the same as the
order of the leaves over here.
We're not really
changing order, we're
just making things a little
shorter to write down.
Same thing over here.
I mean, x1 appears
the left of x2.
Say the order of the
leaves is preserved.
The other cool thing
about compress tries
is you can compute
them in linear time.
But let me tell you why
we're drawing this picture.
We've messed up all these
chunks, all these digits.
What does that correspond
to in this picture?
We've permuted all of the
children in this node.
We've permuted all the
children in this node, permuted
all the children in this node.
But otherwise, the structure
of the tree is correct.
What we wanted to
do was compute--
if we could compute the
compress trie representation
of the original values just
having broken the integers
into these pieces, then if we
had that trie we could just
do an in order traversal,
find the order of the leaves,
then we'd have the sorted
order of the integers.
Instead what we've computed
is we didn't compute
the correct compress trie.
But we computed a
different compress
trie where every node has
its children permuted.
So all we need to do is put
the children within each node
in the correct
order, then we would
have the correct compress trie.
OK, that's why we're doing this.
But first, how do we compute a
compress trie in linear time?
This is a simple
amortization argument.
Remember what we're given.
At this point we are given
the leaves in sorted order.
We've just sorted our things
so all I'm trying to do
is compute the trie of the
stuff above the things.
OK, we're given the leaves of
the trie in the correct order.
I just need to build
the compress trie.
The reason I'm building
a compress trie
is so I can do it
in linear time.
Constructing the uncompressed
trie would take too long.
OK, so how do we do this?
We have our items xn in order.
I want to just insert it
into the compress trie.
So I start with an
empty compress trie.
First thing I do is add x1,
so it's just a single leaf.
Then I add x2 to the
trie, x3 to the trie.
In general, I'll have computed--
I'm going to draw a picture.
How to draw a partial
trie, something like this.
I've computed the left
part of trie already.
All these x1's have been done.
And now I need to
add on the next,
say xi over here somewhere.
So think of how that
would look in the trie.
It has to come off
of the right side,
I guess what would
you call this?
The right spine of the tree.
Some right most node over here.
We want xi to be a new
to the right child.
So one possible
picture is there was
some node which had
some other children,
maybe this one had xi minus 1.
Maybe xi belongs over here.
Maybe this leads to xi
in the uncompressed trie.
This could be a
potential picture.
In the compress trie
this node either exists
or got contracted.
If it exists maybe there
was a previous xi minus 2
belongs over here.
So we already had this node
because it distinguished these
two xj's.
To add the xi is really easy.
I just add a node here and then
which points to a leaf of xi.
So that could be one situation.
The other situation is only
slightly more complicated.
So the other
possibility is this node
didn't exist in the compressed
trie, which means we jumped
over it in the compress trie.
Some number bigger
than 1 here, maybe you
skipped three nodes, who knows.
So now this node matters.
It didn't matter before.
Before it was non-branching, but
now we add xi, it's branching.
All we do is update,
add this new guy,
add the new pointer to xi.
OK, so constant work.
Great, constant work per xi
inserted, linear time overall.
Not really.
I've cheated a little
bit here, which
is how do we know what we're
going to do this operation.
So the changes we make
is constant, that's fine.
But how did I find that
this was the edge where
I need to put xi in?
You can't do it
in constant time,
but we can do it in
constant amortized time.
So what we're going to do
is start at the right most--
that is not very red.
Not a red chalk.
Red chalk.
We start at this leaf, the
rightmost leaf which you go
going right most as possible.
We're going to walk up the tree
until we find the right point.
We're going to spend
linear time this path walk.
OK, how could this
possibly be OK?
I think you believe that I can
do it in linear time, right.
Each point I see--
what is my common prefix?
Actually an easy way
is right up front.
This thing right
here is xi minus 1.
These are single integers.
So I can just compute
their x or, find
the most significant one bit,
which we did with the fusion
tree lecture.
And boom, I know where they
differ in bit position.
By some rounding
I can figure out
which chunk they differ
in, just by dividing,
taking the ceiling.
So I know the correct depth.
And then these numbers tell
me how much depth I'm losing.
As I walk up at some
point I'll discover,
oops, I just jumped
over the depth
I care about where they differ.
And so at that point I
know to do that operation.
So if there are k edges
here on the compress trie,
I can do this in order k
time, k plus 1, let's say.
Why is that OK?
Because my potential
function, amortization
is going to be the length
of the rightmost path.
OK, before my rightmost
path was this thing.
Afterwards, my rightmost path
is going to be this thing.
So it got roughly k
shorter, k minus 1 shorter.
OK, so I charged
this k plus 1 cost
to a potential
decrease of k minus 1.
And so the amortize
cost is only constant.
Easy amortization.
Another way to see
this is, overall
we're basically doing it in
order traversal of the tree.
So whenever we walk up we'll
never visit these nodes again,
because then we go down
at a different place.
OK, yeah, this guy we're
going to walk up again
because in an in order
traversal we would have gone
left and then come back
to it and then gone down.
So overall we're
doing an in order
traversal of the compress trie,
so it's linear time total.
OK.
Still not done though.
What we have so far--
what have we done?
We've taken our numbers,
we've split them into digits.
We randomly permuted the
digits via hash function.
That magically let us
sort them in linear time.
Now we've built a compress
trie of that representation.
The last thing to do is to
fix the order of the children
from each node.
The tree is correct
except for the order
of the children in each node.
So we've kind of sorted a little
bit, but haven't fully sorted.
So that's the last step.
And we're going to do
that with recursion.
We're only going to recurse
a constant number of times.
Recursively sort.
OK, I'm going to walk
through this compress
try trie we've built. And I
guess it looks more like this.
And for each edge I'm going
to write down this key.
First thing you're
going to write down
is the ID of the node.
Let's say the ID is the in order
traversal index of the node.
OK, so boom.
As we traverse the tree we can
just increment this counter.
Then we also want--
what I'm going to put in here
is the actual chunk value
that's at the top of the node.
So something like this,
or I guess this one.
This one consists
of two chunk values.
So it's called c1, for
chunk values, c1 and c2.
It's the first chunk
value and the second chunk
value, first digit
and the second digit.
Just write down the first one.
That's really the only
one we care about.
The second one wasn't
branching so it's no big deal.
OK, so there's some chunk value.
Now, I don't want to write
down the signature chunk value.
I don't want to write
down the hash value.
I want the actual chunk,
original chunk not the hash.
That's why I write
actual over here
and then also, I'm
going to write down
the index of the edge.
So this is the second
edge, for example.
OK, now this is in some
sense the wrong index.
And what I want to compute
is where it's supposed to be.
The edges have been permuted.
So if I sort this
thing, I claim that I'll
find that all the
desired permutations.
OK, why?
Because if I sort by
this triple, first thing
I sort by is by node ID, then
I'm sorting by actual chunk
value, then edge index.
I don't care that I'm
sorting by it, that's
just coming along for the ride.
So what this tells
me is for each node
it gives me the sorted value
of the actual chunks, not
the hash chunks.
And then it tells me the
order they used to be in.
So this is a way to figure
out the sorted permutation
of these things.
This gives you the old index.
And so once you've
sorted them you
know that new correct
order is in order by chunk.
And so this gives
you the inverse
of the permutation over here,
of where each edge should be.
So once I've done
this the last step is
for each node permute
the edges as given
by this inverse permutation.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: Can you
explain again that?
You were basically
sorting three times.
ERIK DEMAINE: No, I'm sorting
these single key values.
The key value, the most
significant part of the key
is this.
The next most significant
part of the key is this.
And the least significant
So imagine concatenating
these things together
into a single key value.
Yeah, good question.
What I'll talk about in a
moment, how big this key is.
But if I sort by the
concatenation of those keys
then what happens is
I'm sorting by this
and then sorting by this.
But really, I'm doing
one sort operation.
This is one recursion.
Other questions?
OK.
Do you see why this
gives us what we need?
For every node we want
to sort all those chunks.
And so this information
is just so we
can keep track of
the permutation
when we're just sorting
by value and not
keeping the permutation.
This let's us keep track of it.
But our real goal is to
sort all the chunk values.
And we add in the node
ID so that we just
learn for every node what
we're supposed to do instead
of globally what we need to do.
Maybe you don't have to
do this but it's easier
to keep the node ID in there.
OK, how many bits
are in this key?
So our whole point was
to make chunks small so
that the keys were small.
But I claim this will be a
little bit smaller than what
we started with.
So the node ID, well,
there's only n nodes,
so this is log n bits.
Chunk value is, I
guess, w divided by log
to the epsilon n bits.
Because there are a log
to the epsilon n chunks,
so it's w divided by
log to the epsilon bits.
The edge index, how many
different things were there?
Is it also w divided
by log to the epsilon?
I guess so.
Depends how you count.
Let me think for a second
how these edge indices should
be stored.
I think I'd like to
store the edge indices--
I don't want to store
the absent down pointers.
The way that I built this
tree, this compress trie,
I was always adding
things to the right.
So it's like OK,
I'm storing here.
Here's the first child,
here's the next child,
here's the next child.
I just keep appending on.
It's like an array that you
can grow to the right, which
you should know how to
do in constant time,
even though linked
list is probably fine.
If there are a
bunch of values here
that are just null
pointers I don't
want to store those
items in the array.
So in fact, the maximum number
of children of a node is n.
I mean, at the worst case you
have branching everywhere.
So this is only log n bits to
store the index in that array.
So it's an extra
level of compression.
I guess I didn't mention
don't store null pointers,
just skip them.
And that's easy to do because
you're always just appending.
And in the end what
do I need to do here?
Step seven is in order
traversal of the compress trie.
And I output all the
leaves I get in order.
And the point is we computed
the compress trie which
has the rough correct
topological structure.
Then we fix the order
within each node,
now we have the correctly
sorted compress trie.
And so you're just doing
in order traversal, output
the leave you get in order.
Boom, we've sorted
all the items.
A little crazy.
So if all we need to do in
the end is in order traversal
then it's fine we don't need
to store the null pointers.
So we don't need to be able
to search in this trie,
so this is enough.
Clear?
OK, the remaining
question is how
expensive is this recursion?
So I computed the number
of bits basically w
divided by log to the
epsilon n, plus order log n.
That order log n won't hurt us.
Now, we started with
integers of size w,
the total size here was w.
Now we have integers that
their size is w divided
by log to the epsilon n.
So we've made progress.
Cool.
How much progress?
Over here maybe.
After, let's say, 1
over epsilon plus 1
recursions we will
have reached b will
have decreased to order log n.
I guess, like 1 over epsilon
log n plus w over log
to the 1 plus epsilon n.
OK.
Right, if we take
w and every time we
divide by log to the epsilon n,
then after 1 over epsilon times
we have divided by log
n, get rid of epsilon.
Do it one more time,
we get w divided
by log to the 1 plus epsilon n.
And at this point
we're in good shape.
If we get the size
of our integers
to be only w divided by log
to the 1 plus epsilon n,
then we can use packed sorting.
Because packed sorting,
conveniently it's
the black box at the
moment, says well,
as long as w divided by b is
a little bigger than log n.
So here we've made it quite
a bit bigger than log n.
I mean, log to the 1
plus epsilon n bigger,
then we can use packed sorting.
Reach base case, and
then use packed sorting.
OK, the only thing is
there's this log n.
Now, epsilon is a constant here,
so 1 over epsilon is constant.
So this is just order log n.
Order log n doesn't hurt you.
I mean, if this happened
to dominate this
then you're saying your values
are order log n bits long,
and so you use radex sort.
So that's not going to dominate.
In fact, you can
prove in this case
it's not going to dominate. w
is at least log to the 2 plus
epsilon.
So you take w
divided by log to 1
plus epsilon, that's
still at least log n.
So this will always dominate.
OK, so we did all
this work and all
we did was reduce our word size
by a log to the epsilon factor.
But that's enough,
because after we
do that 1 over
epsilon plus 1 times
the words are small enough,
or the items we're sorting
are small enough, that we
can use packed sorting.
And boom, we're done.
OK, that is the beauty
of signature sort.
Any questions about that?
Definitely not easy.
But, it works.
The crazy idea is, well,
decompose into these digits.
And when we decompose into
log to the epsilon digits
because that would be enough.
If we can get things down
to a single digit life
would be easy.
Which I guess is kind of
like Van Emde Boas, right.
It's like our lower
bounds from last time.
I don't know.
If we can make it to only
one digit mattered then
we could afford to do it because
each digit is quite a bit
smaller.
It's smaller by a factor
of log to the epsilon n.
So we did that
splitting and then there
was this observation that
most digit values aren't used.
So if we hash then
things got a lot smaller.
Then we can afford to pack sort.
Except that hash didn't
preserve the order.
How didn't it
preserve the order?
Well, when you look
at the compress trie
you see how it got messed up.
Each node got messed
up individually,
but overall the structure
of the trie was correct.
So we did all this work to
get the structure of the trie.
Then we had to fix
the node order.
But that's really just
sorting a single digit.
And yeah, we have to do it for
all nodes but you add them up.
It's still only n items
that we need to sort.
So I wrote that b went down.
n stays the same.
The number of things
we have to sort of
stays the same, which is fine.
We're not trying
to reduce n, we're
just trying to reduce
the size of our items
to be a little
bit smaller than w
so then we can use
packed sorting.
OK, I think I've gone over
this algorithm enough times.
The next step is packed sorting.
If we have integers that are
much smaller than our word,
how do we sort in linear time?
And this is going to be
essentially a fancy merge sort.
This is done in the same paper.
Before we said omega, I'm
going to essentially make omega
a little bit bigger than 2.
So I want to assume
that w is at least
twice b plus 1 log n log log n.
That's just to make
this convenient,
but of course it doesn't really
matter what the constants are.
This will make everything
fit in one word
though, instead of a
constant number of words.
OK, step zero of this
algorithm is the packing part.
We can fit more than one
element into each word.
So put them in.
Now, we have linear
time overall.
This is easy to do.
You have some word already.
Take those items, shift them
left or in the next item,
shift them left or
in the next item,
in the next item.
OK, linear time.
So in the end what it's
going to look like--
oh, I also want to leave a 0
bit in between each of them.
So we're going to have b.
This is going to
be x1 here, x2, xn.
Each of these is b bits long.
And then we have one more bit.
And in fact, the way
we set things up this
is only half the word.
So there's another
half over here, which
is going to be all 0 for now.
So we have one word contains--
sorry, this is not n items.
This is going to
be log n log log n.
Can't fit them all in one word.
That would make
life really easy.
You can fit log n log log
n items in the first word.
Then the next word
is the next log n
log log n items and so on.
Linear time to do that.
Next step, this is an algorithm.
It's not really a step.
I should say these are
things that we're able to do,
and we're going to combine
them in different ways.
So the next thing
to observe, this
is sort of a bottom
up perspective.
So first thing we can do
is pack things into word.
Next thing we can do is
merge two sorted words.
Let's say they each have k items
and k is at most log n log log
n.
And I want to merge them into
one sorted word with two k
elements.
So I have two of these
things and I'll merge them
in sorted order.
And when I did this
packing, nothing's sorted.
But don't worry about
that at the moment.
Just if I had two
these words and suppose
they were already
sorted, then I want
to merge them and make
them still sorted.
OK, I want x1 to be
less than x2 and so on.
How much time?
It'd be cool if you could
do this in constant time
on a transdichotomous rem.
You could do anything
on a constant number
of words in constant time.
We're not going to
achieve constant time,
but we don't need to.
We're going to do
order log k time.
ERIK DEMAINE: This is the
hardest step of packed sorting,
and I'm not going to tell
you how to do it until later.
I will tell you, don't worry.
But this is going to
require bitonic sorting.
So I have to delay
it a little bit.
Suppose you had that for now.
Let me tell you how
the rest is easy.
So many black boxes, but they're
all filled in in this lecture.
OK, next thing you
might ask is, well,
how do I get a sorted word?
I see how to get a single word
that has log n log log n items.
But how would I
sort those items?
Use merge sort.
Here's a merger.
You have a way to
merge two sorted lists,
so use merge sort,
that will give you
a way to sort the whole thing.
So I'm going to merge sort
k equals log n log log n
items into one sorted word.
So I start out with a
word that's unsorted.
I do merge sort.
And I sort them.
So this is not the
whole sorting problem
but it's the one
word sorting problem.
So how long does this take?
Well, it's usual
merge sort recurrence,
but then it's plus how long
it takes me to split the word.
Well, splitting
the word is easy,
you just mask out the
low end or the high end
and then maybe shift over.
So in constant time I
can get the left half
and the right half of the
array, which is the word.
Then the hard part
is merging them.
And merging them is 1,
and that takes log k.
So this is step one.
That's our merger.
And so what does this solve to?
Well, probably easiest to
draw the recursion tree.
So at the root we pay log k.
Then we have 2 times log
k over 2, log k over 2.
So at this level
we're paying log k.
At this level we're paying
2 log k minus 1, I guess.
I'm just going to
call this maybe--
yeah, I do need to do that.
I mean everything is constant
size so you pay a constant.
How many leaves are there
at the bottom level?
k of them.
OK, so at the root
we're paying log k,
at the leaves we're paying k.
This is roughly geometric.
There's this minus 1,
but it's geometric enough
and when you add up all these
levels it's dominated by k.
So this ends up
being order k time.
The minus 1 here turns
out not to matter much.
Cool.
So this linear time sorting
on log n log log n items.
Everything it fits in a word.
Cool, but we're not done yet.
We need another level.
The rest is pretty easy.
It's just scaling up.
OK, let's see.
At this point we're going to
assume that all of our words
are completely full.
So this merging and stuff
was in order to fill up words
and to make those words sorted.
But once we've done that
for each cluster of log n
log log n items, now
we can assume each word
is sorted and completely full.
It has exactly k elements in it.
So each of these r sorted
words has k elements.
OK, so now the issue is
things don't fit in a word.
And so now suppose they
fit in r sorted words.
So supposed we've already made
a sorted list of r times k items
which fit in r words,
each with k items in it.
Then I want to take
two of these lists
and merge them
together and get one
sorted list of sorted words.
So it's 2 rk items that are
distributed into 2r words,
each of size k.
How do I do that
merge in linear time?
And I only need to do it
in r log k time, only.
Yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: I'm assuming k is
the number of items per word?
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah, k
is this from now on.
And there are exactly
k elements per word.
We've already filled up
the word so at this point
we can assume that.
AUDIENCE: But it's exactly
equal, not less than.
ERIK DEMAINE: Right.
AUDIENCE: Because in one--
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah, over here
it's less than or equal to.
I know it's a little confusing.
I use k for different--
call this k prime.
OK, and at this point we've
filled up to this value of k.
Now everything has exactly
log n log log n items.
Thanks.
OK, let's see.
A regular merging algorithm
would take r times k time
because they're r times k items.
But we have this merger
over here, which will
merge two words in log k time.
So that's why it's
going to be r log k.
What's the picture?
Well, let me draw it.
We have a list of words.
A list of words.
How do we merge?
Well, we take the first
two words, merge them.
When we merge them and we know
how to do this n log k time,
that's step 1.
When we merge them
we get two words,
they just are now sorted.
So we've got these
two guys sorted
and then there's the rest.
I'd like to say output
these and repeat,
but that wouldn't
be quite correct.
Well, these guys I can output
because I've got k items here,
k items here.
These are the k smallest
among all of them.
Those must be the
overall smallest k items.
Because I compared k with k.
These higher k
items, I don't know.
They might be good or bad.
So I have to put this high part
back into one of these lists.
You have to think a
little bit about which
list to put it into.
Turns out if you
look at the max item,
say where did this come
from, list one or list two?
You put it into that list.
Let's say this
came from list two.
And you put it back into
list two and then repeat.
OK, so in log k time here
we have output k items.
And so we end up with an r
log k running time overall.
OK, so it's like
regular merge algorithm,
except we use step
one to merge words,
and then there's a
little bit of work.
This is like old merging
algorithm, right?
You take the min and
you put the max back in.
Except now the max
is a whole word.
OK that's how we merge.
Now, why did we do a merger?
Because next thing
we do is merge sort.
And this is the
overall algorithm.
It's one merge sort.
We're going to use
this is the merger
and we're going to use
this as the base case.
So it's actually two recursive
levels of merge sort.
Merge sort is recursive
within step four for a while,
until we get down to the
level of a single word.
Then we use this thing to deal
with things in a single word.
So we end up with t of n
is 2 times t of n over 2
plus n over k log k.
And base case of
t of k is order k.
Why is it all this?
This thing is r.
So we have r log k to do a
merge. r here is n over k.
Why is it n over k?
Because n is the
total number of items.
We had r times k
items, so n equals rk.
So r equals n over k.
That's that.
So this is our merge cost.
This is the cost of 3,
this is the cost of 2.
If we have only log
n log log n items,
so k items, then we can
sort in linear time.
So we just need to
solve this recurrence.
Well, how's it going to work?
It's going to be kind of like
merge sort, but not quite.
Question?
AUDIENCE: When you say-- so
you have-- it's definitely
merging two lists
of sorted words
into one sorted
list of two words.
[INAUDIBLE]?
You may have to do that, right?
ERIK DEMAINE: Say that again.
AUDIENCE: So you
have two sorted--
two sorted lists
of R sorted words.
ERIK DEMAINE: The
words are going
to change, which elements are
in which words are changing.
But that's thanks to
step one, for example.
I mean, step one can
merge any two sorted words
and make one sorted word.
Or actually, one sorted word.
In our case, we're going
to get two sorted words.
That was the picture over here.
I merge the two guys.
I could represent it as one
word that's kind of double full,
and then I can split
that into two words.
So we again need
the split operation,
but split is just a mask
these guys out and you
get the high part.
This is all 0.
Then you shift it
over to the left,
now you've got the high
word over the single word.
So they're shuffling
within those two words,
or within one word,
essentially, via this procedure,
which we haven't covered.
So everything is
going to mix around.
But then there's the low
items and the high items.
And so all the items in
here are less than all
of the items in here.
Other questions?
Cool.
So I need to solve
this recurrence.
So let's draw another
recursion tree.
That's the east way
to solve recurrences.
Root is n over k log k.
Next level down, see
n got divided by 2.
So it's going to be 1/2 n over
k log k, 1/2 n over k log k,
because the n gets divided by 2.
So if I add up
everything on this level,
I get n over k log k.
And in general as I
go down, all levels
are going to sum to this
same value, n over k log k.
So up here we are going
to have a cost of n
over k log k times
the number of levels.
Now, this is where
it's a little tricky.
It's not log n levels
like regular merge sort.
We stop at level k.
So it's going to
be log of n over k.
That's the number
of levels we get to.
Now at the leaf level finally
we have things of size order k,
and we only pay order k.
Great.
And then how many
leaves are there?
There's n over k leaves.
OK.
So, that's an order n cost.
This is order k, that's
n over k, order n.
What's this thing?
Well, what's k?
k was log n log log n.
So this is n divided
by log n log log n.
This, therefore, is
approximately log log n.
So that log log n
cancels this one.
This is approximately log n,
so that cancels with this one.
So this is order n.
That's why we
chose these values.
So this n over k was not
actually that significant.
We could have called that n.
What is important is that this
recursion doesn't work when
you get down to a single word.
Can't do the same strategy.
You need to use a different
merger for single words
because here we have
to do bit tricks.
For this merge
strategy we didn't
have to do big tricks
because everything was bigger
than a word.
The reason why we
have these two levels
is not to make the
time fast, it's just
to make the algorithm work.
I mean, to define the algorithm
there's within a word merging
and over many words merging.
The hard part is this one,
within a word merging.
So that's our next goal.
But if we could do that we
get linear time sorting for
packed sorting when you can fit
log log log n things in a word.
Any questions about
packed sorting?
Good.
So, last thing is how do
we merge two sorted words
into one sorted word.
And this is where we're
going to use bitonic sorting.
See, it says right here, bitonic
sort for merging sorted words.
Here we know what to do.
Much easier in hindsight.
So I'm going to take a
little diversion tell you
about bitonic sorting, briefly.
Because it's NCLRS I don't want
to spend too much time on it,
but it is something we need.
So you need to
know how it works.
So first thing is the idea
of a bitonic sequence.
This is going to be a cyclic
shift of a uni-modal sequence.
So a non-decreasing plus
a non-increasing sequence.
So I want non-decreasing
and then non-increasing.
So this is a bitonic sequence.
I think you know
what this means.
Or it could be a
cyclic shift thereof.
So I could, for example,
take this part here
and shift it over to this side.
So then I'd end up with
this, this, and this.
This is also bitonic.
or I could shift
this whole thing
and put it over there
so I end up with that.
That's also bitonic.
So it basically has one
max, one min if you're
reading it cyclically.
One local max, one local min.
Except, it's non-decreasing
so it's a little messier,
but same thing.
OK, let's go over here.
So if you have a
bitonic sequence
there's something called a
bitonic sorting network, which
you can think of as a
parallel sorting algorithm,
to sort such a thing.
So it's almost
sorted, but not quite.
And there's this
way of sorting them.
So I'm going to draw a picture
to make it easier for me.
It's a little more
annoying to write down
the general algorithm.
But so what I want to do,
suppose the number of elements
is a power of 2.
Here's what I'm going to do.
First I compare the first
and the midway element.
And then the next one with
the next one, and then
the next one with the next one,
the next one with the next one.
For each of these
comparisons I put those items
in the correct order.
So if I do that 3 versus
6, 3 is less than 6,
so 3 stays here, 6 stays there.
5 is bigger than 4 though,
so 4 comes over here,
5 goes over here.
Next is 7 versus 2, so 2 comes
over here, 7 comes over here.
Nine versus 0, so 0 is
over here, 9 is over there.
OK, that's an easy
set comparisons to do.
The nice thing is you can
do all those in parallel.
OK, just to check here.
This was a monotone
increasing sub-sequence
and then a monotone decreasing.
Now, we have increasing
then decreasing.
And then we have
decreasing then increasing.
But if you look at the left
half or the right half,
they are still bitonic.
And that's an invariant.
Bitonic will be preserved here.
Also notice, all the
elements in the left
are smaller than all the
elements in the right.
That's not true for
an arbitrary sequence,
but it will be true
for bitonic sequence.
Essentially the max
is somewhere here
and so it's going to
be spanned by some
of these intervals, that max.
And by spanning those intervals,
and in particular comparing
that guy with
somebody on the right,
the max will get
over to the right
and then the rest of the
increasing and decreasing
sub-sequences will follow.
That's a very
hand-wavy argument.
You can see CLRS for a
way to prove that OK, just
take it for granted now.
Now, we recurse
on the two sides.
So I compare 3 with 2, 4
with 0, I compare 6 with 7,
and 6 with 9.
So what do I get?
2 is less than 3.
0 is less than 4.
Then I compare 6 with
7, so 6 less than 7.
5 is less than 9.
So now I've got four chunks,
this one, this one, this one,
and this one.
I recurse on each of them.
So 0 is less than 2, 3 is
less than 4, 5 is less than 6,
7 is less than 9.
Now I have all my items in
sorted order, magically.
OK, but if you
believe that invariant
that the smallest
n over two items
get to the left and the
larger n over two items
get to the right, then by
induction this will sort them.
Kind of like quick
sort in that sense.
OK.
The cool thing is I can
do all these in parallel,
all these in parallel,
all these in parallel.
So the total time is log k,
if I'm a parallel sorting
algorithm or a sorting network.
And log k is exactly
what I can afford.
So the last thing to do is to
implement an operation like
this, or like this-- this is
kind of the generic picture
here--
in constant time on a word ram.
One other thing,
because I don't want
to sort a bitonic sequence.
That wasn't my goal.
My goal was to merge
two sorted sequences.
I have two sorted sequences,
I want to merge them.
How do I make that bitonic?
I just flip, like that.
I take this sequence
and I reverse it.
If I take a sorted sequence
and reverse it then
it looks like this.
And so then the
result is bitonic.
Then I can use bitonic
sorting to sort it.
So this is the merge
problem and I've just
reduced it to bitonic sorting.
Cool.
Except, how do I
reverse a sequence
in log k time on a word ram?
Cute trick.
If I have a word and it
has many items in it--
that's our picture,
that's our set up here--
and I want to reverse it
over all, what I'll do
is cut it in half, take all
these guys put them over here,
take all these guys
put them over here.
So I've got the right side--
sorry, it's only four--
cells over here.
I've got the left
side over here.
Then I recursively
reverse the sequence
and recursively
reverse this sequence.
And then I have the
reverse sequence.
Right, this is a standard.
One way to reverse items
is to do the big part
and then recursively reverse.
Then I will get, I mean
this is like ab reverse is
equal to b reverse a reverse.
Just a fun fact.
So we're implementing that.
Now how do I do this?
Well, this is the thing I've
been talking about over here.
You want to take the high part
you just mask that part out,
shift it to the right.
You want to take the low
part, just mask that part out.
And so I can take
each of these parts
individually, shift
this one to the left,
shift this one to the
right, order them together,
and I've reversed.
So this takes constant time.
This is recursion but
the total number of steps
will be order log k, which
is exactly what I can afford.
So that's how I do
the reverse part.
So if I want to merge, now
I have a bitonic sequence.
Last thing to do is, how do
I do this bitonic comparison
in constant time.
So, that's next page.
Here's a quick sketch.
I'm going to try to draw
the generic picture.
So the generic picture is
I have this thing which
I call a, this thing
which I call b,
and we basically want to compare
corresponding items in a and b.
Though in fact, there's
another a over here and another
b over here.
In general, there are many
a's, many b's, but they appear
in this nice periodic pattern.
And so I'm just going
to look at one ab pair,
but it's going to simultaneously
work for all of them
with the same operations.
So that's the dot,
dot, dot here.
There's another a
and then another b,
and another a and another b.
So what do I do?
First thing I do is
make 1aa, 1aa, 1aa.
In other words, I
add in these 1 bits.
Remember, we had zeros
there hanging out.
That was when we were
going to use them.
So I set them all to
ones in the a list.
I take the b list, I just
shift it over and leave them
as zeros.
Time for bit tricks.
Then I take this number, I
subtract it from this number.
What do I get?
I get zeros or ones for
whether this bit got
borrowed, which tells
me whether little a is
bigger than little b.
Then I get some junk.
And then I get 0, 1.
Junk.
So on.
0, 1, junk.
So 0 corresponds
to a being smaller
than b, and 1 corresponds
to the reverse.
OK, whatever.
Then I do my usual masking,
just the 0, 1 bits,
then there's some zeros.
OK, here's a new trick
which we haven't seen yet.
I'm going to shift this to the
right by two, or in general
by the size of those items.
So now I have 0, 1 here,
0, 1 here, 0, 1 here.
Each of these bits
might be different.
So I take this,
shift to the right.
Now I subtract.
What this gives me--
so I'm taking 1,
0, 0, 0, minus 1.
What I get is 0, 1, 1, 1.
OK, in this case,
there's just two bits.
Except it's not 1, 1.
It's either 0, 0 or 1, 1.
And then we have here 0, and
then 0, 0 or 1, 1, and so on.
So now these are masks.
The zeros correspond to
when the a's were smaller,
the ones correspond to
when the b's are smaller.
So if I take this [? added ?]
with this, I get the large b's.
If I take this [? added ?]
with this, I get the small a's.
Or one of some of
those combinations.
The point is I take--
I think here I
get the small a's.
And then if I take this thing
and negate it and then mask it
with this I get the small b's.
And then I take this thing--
I ran out of room.
So I've got small
a's, small b's.
I take this thing I shift it
over so I have small b's here.
And then I OR these together,
I get all the smalls.
OK, these are designed to
never conflict because I
took the inversion here.
So I get the smaller of the
a's, smaller of the b's.
So now I put the smaller
things in the right order.
I do exactly the same procedure
negated, and get the larges.
And then I OR these
together and I get sorted.
Well, not sorted.
I get whatever bitonic
sort would have done.
It's doing these pairwise
comparisons by doing this shift
and it's putting things
in the right order.
The small ones always
end up on the left,
the large ones always
end up on the right.
That's the definition of
the operation we want to do.
Bitonic operated.
And because we are just doing
shifts, and subtractions,
and all these things, it works
even though there's not just
one ab pair, but there's
a whole bunch of ab pairs.
They will all be shifted, and
computed, and sorted together.
It's a little hard
to visualize but this
will do one bitonic operation
and a constant number
of word ram operations.
And so you pop out
all these stacks
this gives us a merger, that
gives us packed sorting,
and with packed sorting
we get signature sorting.
Easy, right?
All right, that's probably
one of the most complicated
algorithms we'll
see in this class.
But from that you get
a priority queue that
runs in constant time provided
w is a little bigger than log
squared n.
Boom.